lady gaga is weighing in on Selena  Gomez's decision to take time off  Selena announced her break last month  and Mother Monster was asked directly  about it during an interview with 103.5  KTU is the fame thing really that  serious where it makes you kind of like  take a minute to check yourself I mean  serious is a broad you know term I mean  the but I would say that you know famous  is a very isolating it's something that  it takes a moment for you to stabilize  yourself especially if you're you know  really in it for the music or for you  know your craft because it can be a  distraction from all of those things  Gaga says she took three years  recalibrating or herself and working on  new music I'm just so very very lucky  girl this year to have people really  believe in me Selena says she's  suffering from anxiety and depression  stemming from her lupus diagnosis it  makes you really write your life  subtitles twenty-four-year-old first  revealed she had lupus last year